qué nos pasa
nosotros hoy no somos los mismos
y tampoco nos comportamos igual hay algo
que está cambiando
para dónde va la humanidad
hoy las personas ustedes nosotros nos
estamos desconectando de aquí la gran
pregunta es esa restricción solamente es
entre personas o también está ocurriendo
entre marcas y productos entre productos
y consumidores qué está pasando entre
padres e hijos
qué está pasando realmente 33 empleados
estaban llegando realmente al corazón de
la gente estaba comunicando ustedes creo
que no podemos mejorar esa parte
yo trata de investigar este tema durante
20 años para saber qué es lo que está
pasando dentro de esa caja negra que es
el inconsciente que es el 85% de la toma
de decisiones en cuanto a lo que
nosotros hacemos y decimos y lo que me
da la cuenta es que las personas nos
estamos desconectando porque cada vez y
cuando nosotros realmente estamos siendo
personas totalmente egoístas nos estaban
hartando de ser una sociedad y cada vez
somos más individualistas eso ha hecho
que tanto ustedes como nosotros a veces
vean al prójimo como una competencia
y a veces hasta que un enemigo y es ahí
donde empiezo a investigar un poco más
sobre lo que está pasando y veo estudios
los cuales demuestran inclusive que
entre seres humanos entre hombres y
mujeres es la perspectiva que tenemos
hacia el problema realmente es terrible
los hombres ven a las mujeres como
bichos raros y las mujeres a veces ven a
los hombres como unas bestias salvajes
de las cuales nos tenemos que cuidar es
por eso que david realmente lo que
quiero es presentarles es un suelo de
los estudios pero lo que yo realmente de
hecho tiene muchos estudios que
demuestran básicamente lo que nosotros
hemos estado viendo si hay diferencias
entre hombres y mujeres es porque esas
diferencias están marcadas porque
tenemos un cerebro totalmente distinto
y dentro de eso quiero mostrarles algo
que nos dijo en la universidad de
cambridge los nuestros que han hecho
durante 23 años esto en el
comportamiento de los hombres y las
mujeres y de sus cerebros para entender
algo que es muy pero muy importante
ni siquiera el cerebro del hombre es y
el de la mujer se había más verso
sabiamente quizás una de las veces tiene
el cerebro más grande y más pesado
sabemos eso quiere creer ustedes que
tienen el cerebro más grande y más
pesado los hombres las mujeres
quién da más
la mujer es bueno déjenme decirles que
los hombres pero los hombres realmente
no son más inteligentes como tal
simplemente tenemos un cerebro más
grandes y les voy a explicar por qué es
el cerebro más grande es porque nosotros
tenemos una estructura el tsja tiene más
gruesos más fuertes porque somos más
pesados y en el momento de ser más
pesados generamos una estructura ósea
que permite tener un cerebro mucho más
grande eso espero
pero lo realmente importante de este
estudio es que se demostró
específicamente que no hay una relación
entre los grandes un cerebro y la
inteligencia para tal en unos siguiendo
nuestros estudios bastante interesantes
en los cuales podemos ver cómo la
universidad de california en los cuales
demostrar por qué la mujer tenía quizás
el cerebro de más eficiente de locos si
el cerebro es más eficiente
y uno de esos estudios lo que me
demuestras básicamente que es eficiencia
de la mujer y su cerebro es más o menos
como un carro después o última nave y la
del hombre como un carro promedio
cuál es la respuesta de por qué estas
mujeres que están aquí hoy y las que nos
están viendo tienen un cerebro más
privilegiados sencillo la respuesta es
experta terios o el cuerpo travieso es
una especie de carretera que los
hemisferios con el hemisferio derecho
esta área vida donde pasan las neuronas
y las mujeres al tener una cuarta
estadios al 30 por ciento más grande
hace que pasen muchas más neuronas y en
el momento en que pasan más neuronas
ustedes sean mejores interconectadas y
están preparadas realmente para hacer
muchas más cosas a la vez es ahí donde
entendemos cada ustedes pueden hacer
aquellas cosas que nosotros no es
ayudando entenderlas como tenemos esa
súper mamás como lleven a tener esa
súper ejecutiva que lo pueden todo
cómo llegamos definitivamente a abrir
cosas como las que están viendo en la
pantalla una mujer que mientras está
manejando se está maquillando está
viendo por celular y seguramente está
pensando en otra cosa reformulada no lo
intente
pero definitivamente ustedes tienen una
capacidad superior para ser multitasking
hacer muchas tareas a la vez bien es un
hombre en las mismas circunstancias no
puede ver el mapa y alavés cuando lo
está viendo tiene que bajarle el volumen
al audio volumen a la radio y uno
preguntaría que tiene que ver algo
auditiva con audio visual no tiene que
ver absolutamente nada el tema es que
nosotros como cavernícolas cazadores
decimos sólo estamos destinada puede
hacer una sola cosa bien una de las
presentes se complica porque cuando
luego yo les quiero hablar sobre entra
más neuronal que te mete ese tablero
hacia adentro quiero decirles que
es más intra hemisférico qué quiere
decir eso que cuando está funcionando el
exterior izquierdo quizás en el misterio
de derechos no funciona tanto y
viceversa cuando el derecho está
funcionando el hemisferio izquierdo
realmente está sin función en cambio las
mujeres son inter hemisféricas eso
quiere decir que siempre están
funcionando los sus tres subsistemas
cerebrales y eso es importante porque
justamente el cuerpo calloso hace que
esas neuronas estén chocando y
conectándose para hacer que ustedes
realmente pueden hacer las cosas que
nosotros no podemos hacer
el tema parecería complicado para los
hombres cierto el tema también pasa
porque esto que de alguna forma suena
como una mala como normal diseño para el
hombre realmente le genera una fortaleza
porque saben que el cerebro simple del
hambre
y que nosotros seamos mucho más
enfocados de ser mucho más enfermedad
buscamos el éxito como si fuéramos esos
pasadores de los tiempos de las cavernas
y eso es realmente es nuestra fortaleza
sin embargo y otra cosa importante es
que si bien las mujeres pueden hacer
muchas cosas a la vez cuando les dice
que haga una cosa sencilla
ahí se complican porque ese entramado
neuronal y ese cableado es mucho más
complejo de connotada por eso este
dificulta tanto que se aprende por
ejemplo a salir temprano a una reunión a
una hora pactada
así que ahí estamos entendiendo cosas
que nos pasan en el día a día pero a la
larga es el cazador este caso lo peor
que hace muchos años sólo tenía que
dedicarse a una sola cosa que era
básicamente sobrevivir y traer a la
empresa a traer comida para tal está
desarrollando una habilidad lógica
instintiva pero las mujeres
desarrollaron mucho más importante que
es la socialización entre la gente
en mejorar el hecho de que las mujeres
que utilicen vital elementos pendientes
comunidades y tratar de conectar mejor
ustedes entienden que van a conectar
mejor y sobre todo porque este diseño de
la naturaleza acá natal de alguna forma
lograr que en ciertas partes como la web
ni la boca sin neuronas existan muchas
más logrado que la del hombro hoy son
desgranados poderes importantes cuáles
son esos poderes pues sencillo el
primero que ustedes tienen la capacidad
de tener profundidad si nunca hemos
escuchado lo que es realmente la propia
la presencia y la capacidad que tienen
sobre las mujeres de medular mucho la
voz pero no sólo las médulas entienden y
tratan de decodificar la mediación de
las demás
es ahí cuando nosotros vemos
experiencias como donde una mujer llama
a un hombre y le dice llamar y de
repente un hombre responde que en ese
momento la mujer se voltea y dice aquí
está pasando algo que pasa algo y uno
dice no me pasa nada a ti te pasa algo
no me pasa nada te pasa
injustamente porque ellas necesitan que
manuel en la b2 y sus nunca lo van a
lograr porque nosotros no tenemos esa
habilidad como tal pero adicionalmente
la mujer está dotada una capacidad
comunicacional importante dicho de otra
forma
hablan más
imagínense que un hombre según la
neurociencia hablar entre 5000 y 10000
peleas dependiendo de a qué se dedica
una mujer habla prácticamente de miami
palabras al día repito 21.000 palabra al
día que son tan generosas que a veces
dejan tres mil para hablarlo con el
paria en la noche
así que ya está más entendido el pp el
momento éste se mandó matrimonios que lo
importante es que somos diferentes somos
distintos además van a ser iguales no
pidamos tener la persona igual alguna
porque la naturaleza no nos diseñó así y
de hecho usted tienen que crearse cosas
como por ejemplo cuando tú ya estás
cansada de un hombre está viendo el
televisor quiere simplemente despejarse
y de repente se acerca a la mujer porque
necesitan las palabras y cuando se
acercan tú escuchas una pregunta pero la
pregunta que normalmente no hacen las
mujeres ni amar como éstas no
queriéndose matarlo no cuál es la
respuesta que tiene el hombre pero duele
y cuál es la segunda pregunta que nos
hacen los poderes que hicistes y cuál es
la respuesta es nada eso significa que
los hombres ya no terminan nuestras
cinco mil palabras y me pueden entender
más así que miren ustedes las
importancias ver cómo las cosas bien
ocurriendo y quiero decirles una última
cosa
la naturaleza nos creó con tres
subsistemas cerebrales me explico de
otra forma hay una parte que
definitivamente es racional en la parte
superior que ustedes están viendo
meterse en este momento esa parte del
córtex la parte racional
la parte 1 he acá la particular una
forma analiza la parte jurídica
pero no es la única parte que toma
decisiones hay una parte que se llama el
sistema límbico sede de las relaciones
es el sistema límbico ellos que nos hace
sentir son las nieves la sinestesia y
tienen totalmente la toma de decisiones
y permiten tenemos lo que se llama en su
sistema reptiliano genes de
sobrevivencia
mientras el uno es mágico mientras en
una razona el otro siente y luego toma
las decisiones y son estos tres
subsistemas lo que la verdad no despidan
porque nosotros hacemos lo que hacemos y
por qué nos comportamos como nos
comportamos y aquí
que el hombre por haber sido que saber
desde el inicio es instintivo
pero no sólo instintivo también es
lógico perdiendo cuando se desarrolla se
dio cuenta el hambre que necesita hacer
estrategias para poder casarme con
personas médicas e instintivos sea
racional a muchas personas planas muy
fuertemente las mujeres en cambio tienen
una gran dotación de nacionalidad son
permanentemente emocionales y es ahí
donde encontramos que la mujer tiene
limpia carta que es la primaria
emocional más grande que la del hombre
qué quiere decir esto en otras palabras
que las mujeres tienen una memoria
espectacular y lo recuerdan todo así que
están 20 mi mente no perderá que mujer
porque siempre la mujer va a recordar
toda la información oportuna
totalmente impregnada de nacionalidad y
que la nación la emoción en la energía
que necesita el pensamiento de lamela
para ser recordaré leer de plazo
es por eso que nosotros podemos quizás
no disfrutar algo en la vida de las
mujeres siempre vamos a saber dónde
estás tú le preguntas dónde está esto te
van a decir en la segunda estantería a
mano derecha abajo de la leche
es increíble nosotros no tenemos ese
poder y tenemos que aprovechar el poder
de las mujeres para poderlas
complementados que entendido después del
proyecto algo que es muy sencillo
señores los hombres tienen cosas
que las mujeres no tienen y las mujeres
tienen muchas beneficios que los hombres
si no tenemos si la naturaleza nos
diseño de esa forma es porque
necesitamos ser complementarios y que ni
siquiera las mujeres son esos bichos
raros que nosotros a veces decimos que
solo campestre membre es esa bestia
salvaje dale playa hay que tenerle miedo
y si nos hemos comportado con el
raro de estas molestias
hoy tenemos que cambiar esa actitud
tenemos que hacer un mejor represento de
nosotros mismos porque estamos diseñados
para ser complementarios para estar
juntos para atender clientes no para
ponernos muros
en las situaciones tan complicado nos
necesitamos a los besos con cada una su
fortaleza en cada una también de sus
debilidades el momento entender que si
el machismo no funcionó tanto el
feminismo le va a hacer porque ambos
desde el punto de vista de la
neurociencia tratan de tener el orden y
control sobre los demás y eso es un
problema porque mónica perder que puede
cambiar las cosas en este mundo es el
poder del amor es el poder de estar
juntos el poder de tratar de trabajar en
equipo para sacar las cosas adelante
para sacar este mundo esta ciudad este
país es eterno esta empresa adelante era
sacar también a nuestras familias hay
que meterle ganas vamos con todo que si
se puede y ya saben si conocen la mente
entienden a la gente muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]